kill these animals just for the sake of
their knowledge teeth is a crime it's
thought that the world would never see
her living elephant again it's just too
appalling I'm David that and grunt man
I'm delighted to be here with land Bible
when they know about that the hanging on
by a thread they're remarkably skilled
and bring him back from the birds of
extinction the humanity itself was with
in danger of forty fifty years ago of
exterminating whales because they were
hunting them without any restrictions at
all and it was the first time that I
know of where all the nations around the
world got together and said okay we will
stop hunting whales and they did and
whales are safe from extinction provided
we keep the principles that we are doing
now that there are bundles and people
are saying oh well if this starts
killing him again that's not to kill
these animals just for the sake of their
knowledge teeth is a crime it did and
then thought that the world would never
see a living elephant again is just too
appalling so whatever can be done to
stop it
it should be done one animal which I do
not wish to meet in the wild and I
haven't met in the wild though I've seen
it elsewhere and that's the king cobra
king cobra can grow to twice the height
of a man to go to about twelve feet four
four meters long it rears up and and it
rear ups at the height of a man so you
can look you straight in the eyes it
also makes a growling noise and and it's
very aggressive a one bite certain death
yeah I'm scared of king cobras well
there's a remarkable scientist called
Jane Goodall who has debated our lives
chimpanzees he made major scientific
discoveries
jeez she discovered them using tools he
did all sorts of things and she was a
first scientist and she was young
Angus cattle Tom no experience of Africa
she lived out their lives alongside them
they got them to accept and that was
remarkable in itself since then she's
devoted her life to our life
conservation I think she probably lives
on airplanes I have any I met him many
times but I do meet her every night
again on an airplane and I feel like say
Jane don't you get off anyway but she is
like Sean and woman who has dedicated
life to conserving wildlife on this
planet and she's holy ever